Vladimir Putin has based his personal
popularity, which is the key to his
regimes legitimacy, on the propaganda
narrative that looks like this:
"The motherland is in danger! NATO is about to
attack! But thank God
President Putin can protect Russia and
restore the glory of the Soviet Union." So
to sustain this rhetoric, what might he
do next? Shoot down a US plane over
Syria? Crush a possible color revolution
in Belarus? Send Special Ops into Estonia?
During his meeting with Putin, Trump
should tell him that if Putin
continues his dangerous policies, the US
will increase the domestic political
cost of his foreign policy. For starters,
the legislation passed by the US Senate
would squeeze the two sources of his
country's income: oil and arms exports. We
can send defensive weapons to Ukraine,
dramatically increase our presence on
the eastern flank of NATO, and can deploy
our own cyber weapons. But if Putin
begins to moderate his behavior, looking
to internal reforms - not outward
aggression - for his regime's legitimacy,
the US should be the first one to
welcome this development.
So what should
President Trump tell President Putin at
the G20 Summit? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.